l'immunité vaccinale legras décroché par
un morceau de terre de 17 kilomètres
carrés la plus petite des îles de
l'archipel des açores at en effet décidé
de vacciner l'intégralité de ses 400
habitants c'est une opération très
importante pour nous c'est très émouvant
de savoir que l'on a cette chance s'il
se créer un foyer de kobe d'ici nous
aurions beaucoup de difficulté à lutter
et nous mettrions en danger la santé
publique et la vie des personnes après
avoir reçu il ya quelques semaines la
première dose du vaccin pour lutter
contre la pandémie comme et 19
ces insulaires se verront administrer la
deuxième lors d'une campagne étalée sur
trois jours
je trouve très bien cette initiative car
notre île est petit il y à peu
d'habitants les conditions de santé
d'infrastructures sont limités comme les
accès à l'île vahid corvo devient ainsi
le premier espace sur le territoire
portugais à acquérir une immunité
collective vaccinale que nous couvrons
projet il prit comme il ya peu de monde
accord vaut nous pouvons avoir
l'immunité de groupe si les gens jouent
le jeu et c'est ce qui se passe c'est
sûrement la première région du portugal
voire d'europe à avoir l'immunité de
groupes assez contribuent
particulièrement touchée par une
troisième vague de coronavirus avant de
connaître une accalmie depuis quelques
semaines le portugal prévoit de vacciner
70 % de sa population d'ici l'été
prochain